c'est une partie de l'histoire degré la
ville qui s'écrit à 30 mètres de haut
une nouvelle flèche entièrement au zinc
est hissé sur le clocher de l'église
saint maurice tu as certainement un des
plus grands moments dans ma fonction de
maire il faut déjà fait deux ans que
j'attends ce moment là et puis mon rôle
aujourd'hui c'est un beau jour en juin
2019 une tempête aussi violente
qu'inattendue avait décimé le clocher de
l'édifice des toitures avaient été
détruites et des arbres déracinés par la
force du vent deux ans plus tard c'est
donc avec émotion que les habitants
assistent à cette renaissance
c'est là qu'on s'est mariée c'est là
qu'ont fait nos communion c'est là qu'on
a baptisé nos enfants c'est extrêmement
important pour nous de voir aujourd'hui
cette réflexion c'est cette restauration
qui dit a pris beaucoup de temps et qui
nous a fait beaucoup de souci parce
qu'on s'est dit jamais ça sera refait
quoi faire
la halle à la diète elle y est pendant
que les charpentiers ajuste la pose de
la flèche au sol le prêtre pierre bergé
et béni le coq et la croix qui viendront
compléter le haut du clocher
du père et du fils et du saint-esprit à
manille le coq a toujours des qualités
proverbiale de fierté de courage
d'intelligence et de vigilance la
rénovation de cette partie de l'église a
coûté 150 mille euros